okay thank you and uh thanks to the
committee for inviting me
so i'd like to talk to you today about
some work that i've been doing with a
phd student in my lab jeremy berg
and this is some work developing simple
approximations
to describe the coalescence with soft
sweeps i.e the coalescent where
selection occurs on standing variation
so typically when we think about sweeps
within populations historically
we've been thinking about a set of
haplotypes within a population with some
pre-existing set of neutral mutations
standing in the population
a selected mutation arises on one of
those haplotypes
and under the full sweep model for the
classical suite model that allele is
immediately beneficial
increases in frequency
dragging with it the haplotype on which
it erodes dragging with it the illegal
diversity on the background in which it
arose some of those alleles are going to
go to almost fixation but due to a
combination events during the sweep of
the allele through the population they
won't hitchhike all the way to fixation
and diversity is reduced in that region
okay
so if we're thinking about this in a
coalescent model how we think about this
is that at the selected sites there's
some very shallow genealogy where all of
our lineages are forced to coalesce
back under the selected mutation
as we move out along the sequence away
from the selected model our mutation as
we all know we start to encounter
recombination events and those
recombination events correspond to
lineages recombining out of the swept
backgrounds coalescing much deeper in
time
allowing diversity to accumulate on
these lineages and so diversity will
recover as we move away from the
selected sites so for example here's a
plot just showing you levels of
heterozygosity moving out from the
selected sites along the genome
diversity at the selected site is zero
for both types of sweeps
and a two different selection
coefficients but the recovery of
diversity as we move away from the
selected sites
is much quicker when the selection
coefficient is smaller because there's
much more time for a combination
okay
so the model that people have developed
as a simple way of thinking about this
is that there's some allele sweeping
through the population following
logistic growth
and that allele takes roughly ts
generations to transit through the
population
so at the selected sites all of our
lineages are going to be forced to
coalesce ts generations ago
okay what's happening
to first approximation as we move out
from the selected sites along the
sequence
if we're a neutral locker some genetic
distance r away
then each lineage
has an approximately independent
probability of recombining out of the
sweep
and that probability of recombining out
the sweep
is approximately
the amount of time that there is since
the sweep started ts
times that recombination rate divided by
two and that factor of 2 is there simply
because the trajectory is symmetric
around a half
so that's a simple approximation to the
probability of a lineage recombining out
of a sweep
okay
so if we think that each lineage has an
independent probability of recombining
out of the sweep
then
the number of lineages
that our selective sweep forces to
coalesce
is going to be binomial with this
probability of each lineage recombining
out of sweep independently so the
probability that eye lineage is
recombined out of the suite is simply
the probability of drawing i coins with
heads with this probability
so this is a very simple approximation
to describe the uh coalescent process
under full sweeps and the number of
authors have developed more
sophisticated approximations to this
process but we're just going to stick
with this simple expression for the
moment
okay
so that gives us the probability of the
level of diversity at a distance r away
from the selected sweep
as simply the population scaled mutation
rate
times the expected coalescent time for a
pair of lineages so if we're looking at
the diversity between a pair of alleles
sampled in our population
that's simply equal to the
population scaled mutation rates
multiplied by that underlying pairwise
coalescent type
assuming that ts is very small
there's no chance for the accumulation
of diversity of lineages that fail to
recombine out of the suite
so that's simply equal to pi
the background level of new uh
pairwise diversity
times the probability that one or other
of our pair of lineages recombine off
the selected backgrounds
and so this exponential recovery of pi
as we move away from the selected sites
can simply be seen as the exponential
probability that our pair of lineages
fail to co recombine out from under the
sweep
so that's a crude admittedly crude
approximation
to the effect of hitchhiking for a pair
of sequences but it gives us good
intuition for how these parameters for
example the time it takes to allele to
sweep through the population
and the recombination rates interplay
into describing the patterns of
diversity around a selected allele
okay
so
the thing is that selection doesn't
always act on new mutations the moment
they enter the population right
we can have cases
where there are actually multiple
selected alleles at a lockers each one
of which is present on a different
haplotype
and when selection switches on
those different instantiations of the
selected allele increase in frequency
such that the population is fixed
for a selected uh beneficial
phenotype but no one of these alleles
has gone to fixation
so we can get a case of a soft sweep
rather than a hard sweep
where different copies of the
differently derived copies of the
selected allele have increased in
frequency at the same locus each one of
them
taking the haplotype on which it arose
to intermediate frequency in the
population but at the selected site no
one haplotype has gone to fixation here
due to the fact that the different
mutations were on different haplotypes
the other way in which we can get a form
of a soft sweep
is if our mutation has been segregating
in the population for some amount of
time before it came beneficial so let's
imagine now a single copy of our
selected allele
segregating in the population and that
allele has been at low frequency for
some amount of time before it then
becomes beneficial and gets to sweep
through the population
during the time while that allele has
been segregating in the population at
low frequency
that allele can have recombined onto
different backgrounds
and then when that selected allele races
up to fixation
it takes with it those different
backgrounds it was present on
up into the population but once again no
haplotype has gone to fixation in this
larger region
okay
so those are two different types of soft
sweeps that people talk about in the
literature and there's been a bunch of
work on developing
those models and simulations
so during today's talk i'm first going
to tell you about work we've been doing
developing simple approximations to
selection on standing polymorphisms and
then later on in the talk if i have time
i'll tell you about some work we've been
doing looking at selection on multiple
mutations and thinking about the model
with recurrent selective sweeps
featuring selection on multiple
mutations leading to soft sweeps
okay
so just to motivate this a bit further
there's a number of great examples which
we now know of
where it's clear that the beneficial
allele was segregating in the population
for some amount of time before the
allele became beneficial
so for example
in the case of the eda change underlying
this change in armor plating in these
stickleback populations
it's known that this large effect allele
affecting the plating in these
freshwater populations was segregating
at low frequency in the marine
populations
similarly frequently during
domestication
rather than a new allele being
responsible for some beneficial
phenotype during uh
domestication
plant and animal breeders have made use
of standing variation so there's a
number of great cases of selection and
standing variation in domestication
such as this allele underlying this
phenotype associated with the tb1 change
okay
so what we're thinking about
is an allele segregating in the
population over some relatively long
time periods
and that allele is potentially mutually
evolving or maybe just balanced at low
frequency in the population
at some time in the past that allele has
become beneficial and the allele was at
frequency f in the population when the
allele became beneficial and that allele
has then swept up to fixation
okay
so thinking again about that cartoon of
the haplotypes within the population
what's happened is
our selected allele has recombined onto
multiple haplotypes and i'm showing you
here those different haplotypes the
selected allele has recombined to on the
left hand side of that beneficial allele
in different colours here and those
different haplotypes have been swept up
to intermediate frequency
okay
so
there's two different phases to this
process
there's the selected phase
where the beneficial allele
has formed a relatively large population
of roughly 2n individuals where n is the
adiploid population size
and
assuming that the mutation
has been segregating at a frequency f
over some amount of time in the past
there's a relatively neutral phase where
the alleles being present in two nf
copies within the population
okay
so
in order to think about properties of
genetic diversity in the region
surrounding this sending variance that's
gone to fixation
i'm going to argue that the majority of
what the information present in the data
is contained in the genealogy at the
selected sites and that's how we usually
think about these processes right
there's some genealogy at the selected
sites and we think about the combination
on that genealogy as we move away from
the selected sites
okay
so here's the genealogy
at the selected sites
everyone's sitting under that copy of
the mutation that arose and spread
through the population
as we move out from the selected sites
we can have recombinations on that
underlying genealogy and that's going to
describe patterns of genetic diversity
as we move out from the selected sites
so the first class of recombinations
that we can have occur in this
selected phase of the allele where the
allele has been moving from frequency f
up to fixation in the population
so that's a potentially relatively short
time span
and let's think that that time span
is roughly ts generations
assuming that there's no neutral
coalescence
in this phase
once again
we can think about a probability of a
lineage recombining out
in this selected phase and i'm showing
these special lineages recombining out
each one a special little colored star
pinging out of that trajectory for the
population
so we're going to have a independent
probability
of lineages recombining out during that
selected phase
okay
so after those lineages have recombined
out during the selected phase at some
distance r away from the selected sites
we also have the genealogy of our
remaining lineages in the population
that have failed to recombine during the
selected phase
okay
if we're moving out from the selected
sites in the population and we're
looking at these recombinations
that occurred in this neutral phase when
the allele was segregating at low
frequency in the population
effectively what we're doing
is we're moving out looking at
recombinations once again on that
underlying genealogy
and the different haplotypes present in
our population as we move out from the
selected sites correspond to different
recombinant clades in that underlying
genealogy so here i'm showing you as
hitting that first recombinant haplotype
in the population as we move out from
the selected sites and that corresponds
to this recombination here
in this popular and this phase
corresponding forward in time to a
recombinant haplotype which is
hitchhiked to low frequency in our
sample
moving further out
we hit a recombinant haplotype which
hitchhike to a higher intermediate
frequency in the population
corresponding to a recombination that
sits above a clade of individuals in
that small genealogy at the selected
sites
moving further out again we hit more
recombinants corresponding to different
recombinant ancestors of these clades
okay
so what we're looking at when we're
looking out from the selected sites is
we're looking at a collection of
haplotypes formed by recombinations on
that little underlying
genealogy at the selected sites
corresponding to clays of lineages which
have recombined out from that tree
okay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to develop a simple set of
approximations
to describe the uh coalescent process
in these two in this latter phase and
then use that as a way of thinking about
the properties of recombinations during
that neutral phase
in particular
we're going to make use of this simple
uh result from carsten from back in
2000s so if we think about a neutral
population
the rate of coalescence is roughly one
on 2n per generation in the per pair of
lineages in the standard coalescence
if we're thinking about an allele which
has been segregating at frequency f in
the population for some amount of time
and imagine that this time is relatively
long
compared to the depth of this genealogy
then if we're thinking about the
coalescent in that class
the rate at which pairs of lineages are
forced to coalesce in that small
population two nf individuals
is simply given an expectation
by one on two nf now casting back in
this paper in 2000s shows that this is
the expected the right expected rate of
coalescence
but it doesn't have the right variance
if we use this to parameterize an
exponential
but i'm going to argue for a simulation
that turns out not to matter too much
and that we can think about coalescent
times
in this subpopulation made up of this
derived allele segregating at low
frequency
as simply corresponding to a coalescent
process in a population of two nf
individuals
okay
so that's also not a particularly great
approximation and a number of people
back in the uh
late 90s and early 2000s developed nicer
approximations
but analytically less tractable
okay
so
we're thinking that for a pair of
lineages
their
coalescent time
in this little population made up of two
nf individuals
is simply given by one on two at the
exponential with ranked one on two nf
if one of these lineages is to recombine
then a recombination event has to occur
before they find a common ancestor and
that lineage is going to have to
recombine out of this population
if we're at a distance r away from the
selected sites then recombination occurs
at a rate r per generation
and if the frequency is relatively
constant at f the probability recombines
off the derived background
is simply given by one minus f times r
okay
so this suggests a simple approximation
for the probability that either of my
pair of lineages recombines out of this
derived class before they're forced to
coalesce
and that's simply given by the rate of
recombination for my pair of lineages
two times one minus fr
divided by their rate at which they
coalesce plus the rate at which they
recombine
okay
so this gives us the probability that
our pair of lineages
fail to coalesce in this derived phase
of the trajectory
because they one of the weather of them
recombine out and instead they're going
to coalesce at much greater depth
so first thing to note is that this is
in growing recombination in this
selected phase but it's easy to include
that and we'll do that in just a moment
okay
so we can
let's see
we can write down the pairwise diversity
the amount of diversity we find for
sampling a pair of alleles in our
population
simply as simply as
the level of neutral diversity that we'd
expect in this region if there is no
sweep
and the only way that we're going to get
that neutral level of unit
diversity is if one or other of our
lineages recombines out of the derived
trajectory before they're forced to
coalesce and then they'll cover us at
this much deeper time and have this
level of diversity
so the level of diversity a distance r
away from the selected sites
is equal to that neutral level of
diversity
times the probability that one or other
of our pair of lineages recombines out
from the trajectory
okay so that's a crude approximation to
describe what we'd expect to see in
patterns of diversity as we move away
from a select a selected allele at
frequency f in our population
what i'm plotting for you here
is a demonstration this actually works
quite well in describing levels of
diversity in our population i'm plotting
on our x-axis
the recombination distance moving out
from the selected sites and i'm plotting
for you the recovery and diversity as we
move away from the selected sites
four
alleles which are segregating at five
different low frequencies in our
population and
in the squiggly solid line i'm plotting
for you the simulations under ms
for that parameter model where we
simulate fully stochastic trajectories
and in the dotted line
i'm plotting for you our simple
analytical expression for diversity as
we move away from the selected signs
so it agrees quite nicely
okay
we didn't include the combination in the
selected phase in that expression but
it's easy for us to go back and add that
in
in order for our pair of lineages to
escape
the sweep
and coalesce deep in time having a
neutral level of diversity between them
they can either recombine in the neutral
phase or in the selected phase so the
probability that they do either is
simply one minus the probability they
fail to be combined in this stage
multiplied by the probability of field
to be combined in this stage
and that's simply the expression we
derived before modified by this
recombination rates in that selected
phase
okay
so we now have an expression for
diversity as we move away from a
selected site
which was present at a frequency f
previously in our population
however we'd like to go further than
that
and describe levels of diversity in
terms of higher order summary statistics
we've reminded we might for example wish
to describe the number and distribution
of haplotypes segregating within our
population
as a function of the distance from the
selected sites which has swept through
the population
okay
so let's think that we're a distance r
out from the population from the site
the selected sites and what we want to
know about is the distribution
of the number of haplotypes that the
selected site is present on those number
of haplotypes which the selected site is
dragged up to intermediate frequency in
the population and the distribution
that's equivalent to asking about the
distribution of this colouring which
we've painted on these haplotypes here
that's equivalent to asking
about the number of recombinations
on that small underlying genealogy at
the selected sites
and the number of the descendants
of these recombinant clades in our
haplotype in our sample
okay
so once again
first of all ignoring recombination
in this initial phase of the trajectory
and just concentrating on recombination
in this phase of the trajectory
what's nice is
we're under this simple cartoon model
we're simply asking about the number of
recombinant haplotypes
on this small underlying genealogy
and that's equivalent
to asking
about the number of types and their
frequency
in a un sampling formula on that
underlying genealogy so what we're doing
here right is we're looking back in time
at these lineages coalescing together
and recombination events
in this simple cartoon model
corresponds to alleles in the infinite
alleles model
because every time there's a
recombination out
that corresponds to a new allele a new
recombinant haplotype
okay
so in order to describe the number of
haplotypes and their frequency in the
population
we're simply looking at the u and
sampling formula with a scaled parameter
for nr f1 minus f
and then we're simply thinking about
the scaled rate of coalescence
in this subpopulation which is one on
2nf as before
and once again there's this rate of
recombination
corresponding to alleles moving out of
this
derived class which occur at rate r one
minus f
okay so that's describing the an approx
a simple approximation to the
distribution of the number of haplotypes
segregating in our sample once again
we're initially ignoring the combination
in this first phase of the trajectory
so
let's see how that does
so i'll be zooming in here on the types
that are short enough so that there's
not going to be many recombinations like
the comments just kind of unlikely
so we're here
we're assuming any number of
recombinations out to this point right
so what we're doing is we're looking at
these recombinations
falling on this small tree here right
so if we're at a higher if we move
further out the recombination rates
higher that corresponds to a
combinations occurring further down on
this tree recombining those haplotypes
out right
so we're not making any assumption about
the underlying recombination rate here i
think
we just putting that in as a parameter
whether we actually get to see these
underlying haplotypes they're going to
depend on patterns of diversity rights
uh wait so if it recombines
out but then recombines out again deeper
in
than don't you use yeah so we're okay so
here we're ignoring double
recombinations back into this
environment so we're assuming that f is
low such that if a lineage is lucky
enough to recombine out it doesn't get
to recombine back in
and that seems like a fair approximation
we're usually thinking about f being low
okay
so what you're looking at here
is a
set of simulations and our analytical
predictions
for the probability of the selected
allele
which has gone to fixation ignoring the
combination in that selected phase for
the moment the probability of the
selected allele being on j underlying
haplotypes in a sample of n so for
example out here we're looking at the
selected allele being present on three
haplotypes while here we're looking at
the selected allele being on just two
haplotypes
and we're looking at
as a function
of the recombination rates as we move
out from the selected sites and
we're looking at that for two different
underlying frequencies that the selected
allele was at when selection turned on
okay
so the
different colors
correspond to the selected allele being
on one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten haplotypes
and
once again
the solid lines are simulation based and
the dotted lines correspond to our
analytical theory based on the urine
sampling formula
so close to the selected sites
both the simulations
and our approximations say that the
selected allele should be present only
on a single haplotype because there's
very little opportunity for a
combination
as we move out we see the selected
alleles more likely to be on one
haplotype two haplotypes three
haplotypes and so on as we move out from
the selected sites
and also we see if the frequency of the
selected allele was higher in the
population before selection turned on we
see that we quickly decay away from the
selected allele being present on a
single haplotype and quickly find the
selected allele present on additional
haplotypes as we move out from the
selected sites and once again
we see pretty good agreements between
our simple
approximation and our analytical
prediction and our simulations are in
this case it's not altogether perfect
but it's still doing a pretty good job
in describing uh the haplotype
distribution as we move out from the
selected sites okay
so given the distribution of haplotypes
within the population
under our well where we assume we get to
see those haplotypes we can then switch
and calculate basic other summaries of
patterns of diversity as we move out
from the selected sites
so for example
we can think about the number of
selected of segregating sites that our
selected allele is present on as a
function of the recombination distance
from the selected site
so to do that
we simply need to think about how many
different clades of individuals
our
selected allele gets to be recombinant
on the background of so we can sum over
the probability that our selected site
is present on i distinct haplotypes over
n and conditional on being present on i
distinct haplotypes out of n there's eye
distinct haplotypes which contribute to
diversity in our region and so then
we're simply taking the number of
selected of segregating sites
conditional on there being eye
underlying draws
from the population so we can write our
number of is expected our expected
number of segregating sites
as a function of this underlying
distribution of the number of haplotypes
in our population
so what you're looking at here is that
number of select segregating sites
and here once again
we're looking at our
simple approximation
developed based on this simple cartoon
model of how selection and standing
variation works
and in the solid line
you're seeing the
predictions based on ms simulations
so once again
we see that there's quite good agreement
though by means perfect as this does
seem to be a slight bias
in the agreements
between our approximation based on the
simple cartoon model of the genealogy at
the selected sites and simulations under
ms
okay
so
we can extend this approximation
to
describe
what we'd expect if we allowed a
combination to occur during that
selected phase as well
in that case
once again we can assume that each
lineage has an independent probability
of recombining out during that selected
phase and those remaining lineages which
fail to recombine out during that first
phase of the trajectory
are going to coalesce during according
to this infinite alleles model so we can
count up the number of distinct
recombinant haplotypes which are
selected allele is present on at a
particular recombination distance from
the sites
actually
it's about the previous part so don't
answer if it okay it pulls you back but
do you want me to go back or well i'm
just wondering if you also neglected the
mutations that happened within the f by
this yeah so we're implicitly explicitly
ignoring mutations during this part of
the trajectory so we're
implicitly assuming
that this is a very short time compared
to the uh
call listen to that yeah and so the
coalescent time in the population
and that seems to be doing an okay
approximation
so this approximation is going to start
getting worse and worse right
potentially as that allele starts
becoming more and more common in the
population in that case the coalescent
times within that derived class are
going to start resembling those in the
larger population and so these
approximations are going to break down
and also this approximation that
lineages recombine out of the derived
class is also going to break down that
assuming they don't recombine back in
okay
so we can also in this case
when we allow a combination
in the selected phase and in this
neutral phase write down the probability
of our selected sites being present on j
haplotypes in a sample of n
now
we allow our haplotypes to first of all
have an independent probability of
recombining the selected phase
that corresponds to a binomial
probability of the number of haplotypes
that we combine in this phase
so we're assuming that i
lineages i haplotypes fail to recombine
in this phase
in that case
we can work out that they also then have
to recombine out in this later phase and
we can simply sum over whether a
combinations occur in this first phase
or the second phase to describe the
number of recombinant haplotypes present
in our sample
okay
so
this simple approximation
gives us a way of thinking about
the distribution of haplotypes
segregating in our sample after a
selected site has just gone to fixation
it's nice because it gives us relatively
simple
analytical expressions
for these underlying for these
parameters such as pairwise diversity
and number of segregating sites as
simple functions of that underlying
frequency of the selected layer when
selection began and the time at which it
swept through the population
it's also nice because it starts to
suggest ways of doing inference
on models well of selection and standing
variation due to the simple form of this
uh model that we're proposing
so using these ideas
we're starting to develop simple
inference methods
to try and estimate parameters such as
the strength of selection and the
frequency of the selected layer when
selection began
thinking about the number of haplotypes
that our selected site is segregating on
at various distances from the sweep
so as a first step towards doing this
although admittedly it's very
provisional
we started to develop simple approx uh
approximate likelihood formulations to
calculate the likelihood of a particular
time of select the sweep sweeping
through the population
and the frequency it was segregating at
thinking about if we could actually
observe these underlying haplotypes
segregating in our population
and to do this we use the simple product
of approximate conditional likelihoods
similar to that in liam stevens to
calculate the probability of a set of
colorings of these different haplotypes
as a first approximation to say if we
could actually observe these underlying
haplotypes could we hope to actually
estimate f or is it intrinsically a hard
problem and so it's not worth it
developing further approximations
so we're doing this
what i'm showing you here are a set of
simulations
and we've simulated under a set of
different true f parameters
one percent two percent three percent
four percent five percent corresponding
to the frequency that the selected layer
was segregating at in the population
before selection began
and
using the simple approximate conditional
likelihood similar to leon stevens
we've assumed we can observe the set of
underlying colorings in the population
and estimated this f parameter
and what i'm showing for you in which
each case
is a set of simulations at a particular
true f value
and i'm showing you our estimated mle
and confidence intervals based on that
likelihood surface we construct using
leon stevens
so we can see that even if we observe
the underlying coloring of these
different haplotypes within our
population
we're doing a really quite poor job of
estimating this parameter f
assuming that we have far more
information than we likely do have
assuming that we have access to these
underlying haptotypes we see that there
is some correspondence between our
estimated f and our true f
and in some cases we're probably quite
good at excluding the idea that the
selection turned on the moment the
allele started in the population f is
zero but beyond that we're going to have
really quite a poor job of estimating
that underlying frequency
a comment if you don't mind sure it's
well known that we have this week you
have a kind of sarcastic phase at the
beginning where the uh
where it's not so different from
neutrality then there's a deterministic
phase almost an effect and then you know
so
because of that stochastic phase um uh
i mean when the sweep takes off
is going to be the frequency may be
quite different from the initial air
well so the the initial stochastic
phrase right depends on how strong
selection is only only moderate yeah you
know the deterministic phase is going to
kick in at a place where you don't
really know what f is yeah so i suspect
that that's although to be honest here
we're thinking about f
being something that's well away from
the boundary right we're thinking about
f being one percent where even weakly
selected alleles are going to behave
deterministically above one percent
i mean the general point is right that
we're going to have trouble estimating
this parameter there are going to be
lots of situations where sweeps
on uh standing variation if the
frequency is low are going to look quite
like sweeps off from uh
new mutations simply because of that
stochasticity in that initial phase of
the trajectory
yeah can you use this as the basis
yeah so i think we can use this as a
basis for a test of whether f is zero
and i think we're going to do a
reasonably good job of excluding f is
zero
in some cases but to be honest you know
having gone through all of this
basically if f is
high enough that you can tell it's not
zero you're probably not going to see
much of a sweep anyway right
so in some sense it's gonna be hard to
estimate and separates whether there's a
sweep
if there's so
if it's a sweep from stunning variation
where you can say sweep from standing
variation you probably can't estimate
how quickly it transited through the
population
or you can estimate that it translates
into the population quickly but you're
not going to be able to estimate f
because it looks like a hard sweep even
if it started from low frequency
yeah so if the selection on a recessive
alleles get even more complicated and in
some ways one of the reasons for doing
this and developing these signal
analytical approximations
is just a way of making this point that
even if we get to observe far more
information such as the genealogy of the
selected sites the colorings of these
haplotypes there's still incredibly
little information for us to extract
about this so if we try and do this
using real data putting the
complications that we don't get to see
the genealogy we don't get to see those
haplotypes it further complicates the
problem
as additional leverage if you have a
second population or a time series
population how much does that help
yeah so from steve's talk right if you
have a time series you potentially do
get to see more of that trajectory the
problem is if your allele has been
segregating at a frequency of say one
percent in the population unless you've
got very large ancient samples in your
car loss in a few years time you're not
going to get to see those allele
segregating rates so alleles are going
to be coming up from relatively low
frequency could still be standing
variation in our population but we're
going to miss them unless we have very
large samples in the past right
if you have a second population you
might get to see that allele segregating
in that population and that's
interesting as well but once again
there's a broad parameter range while
this allele could have been you know
present at one in a thousand frequency
where we're not necessarily going to get
to see that in the present-day sample
right but if you catch it in the face
so if you have you mean you capture it's
been a partial sweep in one of the
populations
in that case so if the allele was
partially swept into the population
right and you've been lucky enough to
catch it on its way to fixation or it's
uh somehow over-dominant so it's trapped
in the population
you basically have the same problem as
you have here right in this case we talk
about the alleles sweeping up to
fixation in the population if i told you
that it just swept to 20 frequency in
the population we'd still be in a
semi-state where we get to talk about
the combinations in that phase where
it's sweeping to twenty percent say you
have these two time points you have the
points where it's at twenty percent of
the importance where it's fixed yeah
perhaps a number of different types that
they're all coordinating the fixing or
something like that
yeah so i i think that you know there is
more information to be gotten from time
series looking at these alleles right
that's definitely going to be true
that's going to increase the amount of
information you have
but
it's still fundamentally difficult to
distinguish with an allele sweeping from
low frequency
or from a frequency close to zero
we're still as you know nick was
pointing out there's still this
stochastic phase at the start of the
selected sweep where the combinations
can occur
we're sort of getting some amount of
information about that by looking at
patterns of haplotypes in these
different populations
or you know different time points but
there's still a lot of uncertainty about
that underlying genealogy at the
selected sites
is there an effect of sample size here
so if you're able to sample thousands of
individuals
and you get a much finer resolution on
all of those recombination events and
new mutations that have risen very
recently and in the past
yeah so i mean if you can get better
resolution but still the problem so if
you're talking thinking about getting to
sample thousands of individuals right
they still coalescing remarkably quickly
and you're still looking at a few you
know recombinant clades those clades are
now very large but they're still
inherent stochasticity in the size of
those clades because of that underlying
coalescence process right
okay
hi i was wondering about the
appropriateness of um applying the u n
sampling formula so if you say there's
no mutation it means that there's or if
you assume there's no mutation it means
that you're assuming recent coalescence
which means that you're assuming a small
population size but my understanding of
the unsampling formula is that it holds
in situations and one of the assumptions
is that you have large n so i was
wondering if you're worried about the
asf or the unseparated formula breaking
down in the scenarios that you're
looking at which is small population
sizes yes so
it is a concern right that we're
thinking about this small population
however this small population of uh 2nf
individuals that may still be large
enough for the coalescence to hold right
so if n is large even if f is relatively
small such as one percent this may still
be a very large number of individuals
who are carrying the selective allele as
we decrease that frequency down towards
zero we are going to run into problems
with having a very small number of
individuals and there's gonna be a
stochastic population size here right
but in that case individuals are going
to be coalescing incredibly rapidly
whether it's under the coalescence or
under the full right fischer model right
there won't be much time for a
combination and we'll be in that phase
of being back in a full suite
okay so
sure
i i've given up on getting to the second
part
of selection so the strength of
selection right is all in that
that ts right it's all in the number of
lineages that get to recombine out in
this phase
well they do they're going to be
singletons in the sample right if we
think there's no coalescence in this
phase there's a set of lineages that get
to recombine out that's parameterized by
ts
this number of lineages that get to be
combined out in this space so there'll
be a set of singletons and how many they
are as you move out from the selected
sites
is going to be determined by the
strength of selection it's going to be
determined by that timeline transits
with your population rights
and so that was what i was saying about
i think there's a confounding that will
either be able to estimate something
about the strength of selection because
the allele came from low frequency we
get to estimate how quickly it went
through the population
or we'll be able to say that the allele
was present as standing variation
because f is non-zero but at least for
contemporary data in that case we
probably don't get to estimate the time
at which you're transiting through the
population
simply because most of the
recombinations occurring in this phase
rather than this space
well again i mean if you want to go on
that's fine no i pretty much
the problem is i've given this half
before i haven't given the second half
before so i was excited to get to that
if i should remember to flip it in the
future
well one more question okay so what what
happens if you use a
you know data in aggregate for
for uh
you know many
many sites together so you look around
just an arbitrary idea around all
substitutions of a certain type yeah
so we're thinking about doing this
actually in maze where they have a
number of potential domestication levels
and in that case we're thinking about
learning in aggregates about the
properties of selection of standing
variation for domestication alleles but
also we could potentially do this in
aggregates for all say non-synonymous
sites just to pick a class at random
and look but then we'd have to think
about haplotype patterns rather than
just pine because pies you know sort of
yeah
not a way of deconfounding f from the
time at which these alleles transition
population but how well would it do i
guess would be the question or if you
have a sensor uh
it would do better than nothing but yeah
i think it's hard to estimate these
parameters right
okay okay thanks thanks